♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT"."
SOMETIMES A SINGLE PICTURE SO
PERFECTLY CRYSTALLIZES A MOMENT
THAT YOU WANT TO HANG IT IN A
MUSEUM AS A TESTAMENT TO
HISTORY.
DOROTHEA LANGE A POSTHUMOUS
PHOTOGRAPHS OF MIGRANT
FARMWORKERS IN THE 1930s WERE
LIKE THAT.
THEY CAPTURED THE SUFFERING OF
THE GREAT DEPRESSION
GREAT DEPRESSION MORE POWERFULLY
THAN ANY GOVERNMENT REPORT EVER
COULD.
THE IMAGE OF THE SECOND FLAG
RAISING OVER IWO JIMA WAS SO
POWERFUL THAT WE CAST IT IN
BRONZE.
THE MEMORY OF THE GRIT AND
COURAGE OF OUR MARINES IN THE
SECOND WORLD WAR.
THOSE IMAGES SUMMED UP ENTIRE
PERIODS OF AMERICAN LIFE.
SO WHAT SUMS UP HOURS?
WHAT PICTURE TELLS OUR STORY?
WELL, TONIGHT WE’VE GOT IT FOR
YOU.
DECADES FROM NOW OUR DESCENDANTS
WILL LOOK AT THIS ONE IMAGE AND
KNOW WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO LIVE IN
AMERICA IN THE YEAR 2020.
WE WILL SHOW IT TO YOU IN JUST A
SECOND.
BUT FIRST, SOME CONTEXT.
GAVIN NEWSOM IS THE GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA, OUR LARGEST AND FOR
A LONG TIME ARE MOST PROSPEROUS
STATE.
ABOUT 40 MILLION PEOPLE LIVED IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO FAR TWO OF THEM UNDER THE AGE
OF 18 HAVE DIED OF THE COVID-19
VIRUS, SO NATURALLY GAVIN NEWSOM
HAS SHUT DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE.
BUSINESSES ARE SHUTTERED, PEOPLE
WEAR MASKS EVEN AS THEY EAT.
LARGE GROUPS ARE FORBIDDEN TO
CONGREGATE.
THANKSGIVING ITSELF IS ON ITS
WAY TO BEING CANCELED.
IT’S A TOUGH BOY TO LIVE, BUT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE NO CHOICE.
THIS IS SCIENCE, PEOPLE!
AND GAVIN NEWSOM IS CALIFORNIA’S
EPIDEMIOLOGIST IN CHIEF.
HE COMMANDS OBEDIENCE AND THE
SERFS OBEY.
WITH THAT IN MIND, THE CHRONICLE
BROKER PRETTY AMAZING STORY THIS
WEEK.
THE GOVERNOR RECENTLY ATTENDED A
BIRTHDAY DINNER UP IN ONE
COUNTRY AT THE FRESH LAUNDRY,
ONE OF THE BEST AND MOST
EXPENSIVE RESTAURANTS IN THE
WORLD.
THERE WERE 12 PEOPLE AT HIS
DINNER AND CIVILIANS, THAT’S
NUMBER SEEM TO BE A CLEAR
VIOLATION OF HIS OWN RULES, BUT
AS WE WERE TOLD, IT REALLY
WASN’T.
IT TURNS OUT THAT HE WAS SIMPLY
CELEBRATING THE BIRTHDAY OF A
LONGTIME FRIEND OF HIS, A
LOBBYIST ACTUALLY CALLED JASON
KENNY.
A SPOKESPERSON FOR KENNY
DESCRIBED THE NIGHT THIS WAY.
"THIS WAS A SMALL, INTERMITTENT
HELD DOME OF 12% AND ARE HELD
OUTDOORS WITH FAMILY AND A FEW
RIGHT.
TO SALARY TO 50 BIRTHDAY."
IN OTHER WORDS, NO BIG DEAL.
FOR HIS PART, GOVERNOR NEWSOM
WAS [INDISCERNIBLE] "OUR FAMILY
FOLLOWS THE RESTAURANT HEALTH
PROTOCOLS AND TOOK SAFETY
PROFESSIONS.
SO REALLY, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
IT WAS NOTHING.
JUST A SMALL, INTIMATE DINNER
HELD IN NATURE UNDER GOD’S BLUE
SKIES, JUST A FEW RIGHT.
STAYING SAFE AND FOLLOWING THE
PROTOCOLS TO THE LETTER.
AS MANDATED BY THE STATE THAT IN
FACT THEY RUN.
SO RELAX, PEOPLE, NO ONE IS
GETTING RONA HERE.
THAT WAS THE STORY.
ANOTHER PHOTOGRAPH.
WE HAVE THE PICTURE THANKS TO
FOX 11 IN LOS ANGELES, ONE OF
THE RARE LOCAL STATIONS BUT
STILL DOES REPORTING.
IT’S A PICTURE OF THE BIRTHDAY
DINNER UP IN NAPA.
IT TURNS OUT IT WAS NOT HELD
OUTSIDE, IT WAS HELD IN A
PRIVATE ROOM AND NOT A SPACIOUS
PRIVATE ROOM EITHER.
ALL 12 PEOPLE WERE PACKED IN
TIGHT, SHOULDER TO SHOULDER.
BREATHING ON EACH OTHER.
NO SOCIAL DISTANCING HERE.
NOT ONE OF THEM IS WEARING A
MASK.
A STEAM ROOM IN CENTRAL HON
COULD NOT BE MORE CONTAGIOUS
THAN THIS DINNER.
GAVIN NEWSOM ’US BIRTHDAY PARTY
WAS A GERM FACTORY AND HIS
GUESTS WERE HUMAN PETRI DISHES.
BUT WHAT A GUESS LIST IT WAS.
NEXT TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM’S AT THE
CEO OF CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND ONE OVER FROM
HIM, ONE OF THE STATE’S TOP
HEALTH LOBBYISTS.
TOGETHER THE TWO OF THEM ARE
PRESENT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PHYSICIANS, CREDENTIALED MEN OF
SCIENCE AND WOMEN OF SCIENCE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO IF YOU’RE WONDERING WHY IF
YOU LIVE IN CALIFORNIA YOU CAN’T
HAVE THANKSGIVING THIS YEAR OR
VISIT YOUR MOTHER SHE DIES ALONE
IN THE HOSPITAL, IT IS BECAUSE
OF THEM AND PEOPLE LIKE THEM.
AND YET THERE THEY WERE, EATING
$300 TRUFFLE PASTA AND LIVING
WITH THIS PANDEMIC THING NEVER
EVEN HAPPENED.
THE PICTURE OF THEM DOING IT
KNOWN HENCEFORTH THE HISTORY AS
THE FRENCH LAUNDRY PHOTOGRAPH,
IS THE YEAR 2020 CONDENSED TO
ITS ESSENCE.
HERE YOU HAVE PLUTOCRATS DINING
WITH LOBBYISTS, IGNORING THE
VERY ORDERS THEY ARE SO
SELF-RIGHTEOUSLY IMPOSING
OTHERS, GORGING THEMSELVES IN
SECLUSION AS THE PEOPLE THEY’RE
SUPPOSED TO BE HELPING WITH HER
AND DIE.
AND THEN WHEN THEY ARE CAUGHT,
THEY LIE ABOUT IT.
HOW PERFECT IS THAT?
IT’S ALL THERE, EVERY ELEMENT.
HYPOCRISY, GREED, SELFISHNESS,
STUPIDITY.
THIS IS OUR NATIONAL MOMENT IN A
SINGLE PICTURE.
MOVE OVER, DOROTHEA LANGE.
SO WHAT’S GAVIN NEWSOM’S
EXPLANATION FOR THIS PICTURE?
INTERESTED IN EQUAL TIME, IN
FAIRNESS, WE WILL SHOW TO YOU
NEXT.
>> I MADE A BAD MISTAKE.
INSTEAD OF SITTING DOWN, I
SHOULD HAVE STOOD UP AND WALKED
BACK, GOT IN MY CAR AND DROVE
BACK TO MY HOUSE AND INSTEAD I
CHOSE TO SIT THERE WITH MY WIFE
AND A NUMBER OF OTHER COUPLES
THAT WERE OUTSIDE THE HOUSEHOLD.
YOU CAN QUIBBLE ABOUT THE
GUIDELINES, ET CETERA,
ET CETERA, BUT THE SPIRIT OF
WHAT I’M PREACHING ALL THE TIME
WAS CONTRADICTED AND I GOT TO
OWN THAT SO I WANT TO APOLOGIZE
TO YOU.
>> Tucker: OH, YEAH.
WHEN I SOUGHT I SHOULD HAVE JUST
WALKED OUT, GOT IN THE CAR AND
DRIVEN HOME.
OKAY, GAVIN.
WITH NO IDEA THERE WOULD BE A
DOZEN PEOPLE AT YOUR OWN PARTY.
YOU’RE THE GOVERNOR, BUT YOU
NEVER SAW THE GUEST LIST.
YOU WERE TOTALLY SHOCKED.
THAT’S RIDICULOUS.
IT’S TOO STUPID TO BE AN
EXPLANATION AND WE ARE STUPIDER
FOR PRETENDING TO BELIEVE IT.
WHY NOT JUST TELL THE TRUTH,
WHICH IS I DON’T REALLY TOTALLY
BELIEVE EVERYTHING I SAY, AT
LEAST NOT ENOUGH TO LET IT
INTERFERE WITH DINNER.
THAT’S THE TRUTH.
YOU KNOW WHAT, HE KNOWS IT.
BUT HE’S FORCING US TO PLAY
ALONG WITH AN ABSURD LIE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, AT LEAST
GAVIN NEWSOM DIDN’T FOLLOW THE
LEAD NANCY PELOSI AND BLAME THE
RESTAURANT.
HE DIDN’T ACCUSE THE MAITRE D’
OF SETTING HIM UP AS PART OF A
CONSPIRACY AMONG THE FAMOUSLY
RIGHT-WING RESTAURANT COMMUNITY
IN NAPA.
IF THE FRENCH LAUNDRY PROBABLY
WON’T SUFFER THE SAME FATE AS
PELOSI FOSTERED AS HAIRSTYLIST,
AT LEAST AS LONG AS THEY STAY
QUIET ABOUT IT.
AND TO CREDIT, GAVIN NEWSOM
DIDN’T FOLLOW THE EXAMPLE OF
DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
SHE HAS REFUSED TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AS SHE PARADES AROUND
THE HALLS OF THE UNITED STATES
SENATE AND PRIVATE AIRPORT
TERMINALS MASSLESS AND EXPOSED.
BREATHING ON PEOPLE, INFECTING
THEM.
NO EXPLANATION FOR THAT.
AND TO BE FAIR, ONCE AGAIN,
GAVIN NEWSOM’S EX-CLINICIAN,
THOUGH OBVIOUSLY UNTRUE, IS
STILL BETTER THAN WHAT HIS BODY,
THE LOBBYIST, THE DIE THEY
WORKED ON THAT GUY THEY WERE
HAVING THE DINNER FOR HAS COME
OUT WITH.
THROUGH A SPOKESMAN HE SAID THE
GUESTS SPECIFICALLY REQUESTED
OUTDOOR SEATING AND IT WAS
PROVIDED BY THE RESTAURANT.
INDOOR SEATING, RATHER, IT
INDOOR.
THAT’S WHAT THEY REALLY WERE
DOING.
HE IS SAYING THEY WERE OUTDOORS
BUT NOW WE HAVE A PICTURE
SHOWING THAT AND HE STILL
CLAIMING IT.
NO, IT WAS OUTDOORS.
IN OTHER WORDS, IGNORE THE WALLS
AND THE ROOF.
WHAT LOOKS LIKE INSIDE WAS
ACTUALLY OUTSIDE.
GOT THAT?
UP IS DOWN, BLACK IS WHITE, WAR
IS PEACE, TRUST ME, NOT YOUR
LYING SENSES.
IF ONLY THE CRIMINAL PADDLE
BORDERS HAD THOUGHT OF THAT.
THIS SPRING, POLICE IN
CALIFORNIA HUNTED DOWN A LONE
MAN PADDLE BOARDING IN THE
PACIFIC OCEAN.
HE WAS OFF THE COAST OF MALIBU,
PROBABLY INFECTING THE SEALS.
THEY SAW THIS, THEY GOT ON
BOATS, THEY ALERTED THE
COAST GUARD AND IN SHERIFF PUT
THIS CRIMINAL IN HANDCUFFS.
THEY ARRESTED HIM AND THREATENED
HIM WITH SIX MONTHS IN PRISON
FOR BREAKING CORONA LAWS.
IN THE MEDIA IN CALIFORNIA
TREATED IT LIKE IT WAS TOTALLY
NORMAL.
>> ACROSS THE COAST IN
CALIFORNIA, FIVE IN HANDCUFFS
FOR BAD BEHAVIOR.
ONE MAN ARRESTED IN MALIBU FOR
PADDLE BOARDING IN THE PACIFIC
WHILE 22 SUNSET SEEKERS IN
SoCAL WERE CITED FOR
TRESPASSING ON CLOSED BEACHES.
>> Tucker: THEY LITERALLY PUT
HIM IN HANDCUFFS FOR PADDLE
BOARDING ALONE.
THEY DIDN’T EVEN CLAIM IT WAS A
THREAT TO MARINE LIFE.
THEY DIDN’T EVEN MAKE UP A
PRETEXT.
THEY JUST DID IT AND LIKE SEALS,
EVERYONE APPLAUDED.
SO THE PADDLE BORDER GETS
ARRESTED, GAVIN NEWSOM GETS TO
DINE IN PEACE.
WHAT’S THE LESSON HERE?
YOU KNOW THE LESSON, IF YOU WANT
TO LIVE LIKE A HUMAN BEING
YOU’VE GOT TO GET ELECTED TO
SOMETHING AND THEN YOU CAN BREAK
YOUR OWN RULES.
OTHERWISE DON’T EVEN THINK ABOUT
IT.
HERE’S L.A. MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
EXPLAINING HOW HE WILL HANDLE
PEOPLE WHO DON’T OBEY.
>> THIS HAS REALLY BEEN
MARVELOUSLY EMBRACED BY 99.9% OF
PEOPLE.
WE SEE IT IN THE TRAFFIC DATA,
THE CELL PHONE DATA BUT WE ARE
GOING TO HUNT DOWN THAT LAST .1%
AND SAY YOU’VE GOT TO GET
INSIDE, YOU’VE GOT TO CUT IT OUT
AND YOU GOT TO DISTANCE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, YOU’VE GOT TO
CUT IT OUT, GET INSIDE AND
YOU’VE GOT THE DISTANCE AND IF
YOU DON’T CUT IT OUT, ERIC
GARCETTI WILL CUT YOUR POWER.
JUST LIKE THEY DO IN CHINA.
NO UTILITIES FOR YOU, CORONA
PHELAN.
IF YOU WANT TO BREAK THE LAW,
YOU HAVE A NONSTRETCHABLE ITCH,
GO AHEAD AND LOOT TARGET OR
TORTURE FAST FOOD FRANCHISE OR
BEAT UP AN OLD LADY.
THAT IS FEDERALLY PROTECTED
POLITICAL SPEECH BUT AUTHENTIC
HUMAN CONTACT YOU MARK ONLY THE
RULING CLASS GETS THAT.
SO WHAT IS THIS EXACTLY?
IT’S HYPOCRISY OF COURSE.
THAT WORD IS NOT BIG ENOUGH.
THIS IS NOT CONVENTIONAL
HYPOCRISY.
THIS IS -- LET’S STOP LYING --
AN ACT OF HOSTILITY AGAINST THE
POPULATION OF THE COUNTRY.
THEY DESPISE YOU, THEY ARE
FLAUNTING IT.
THIS IS HOW PEOPLE WHO DON’T
LIKE YOU BEHAVE.
THEY FORCE YOU TO DO ONE THING,
THEY DO ANOTHER, THEY GET
CAUGHT, THEY ARE NOT EMBARRASSED
AND THEY KEEP FORCING YOU TO DO
THE THING THEY’RE NOT DOING.
THAT’S AN ACT OF HOSTILITY.
THEY DON’T LIKE YOU.
LAST MONTH, FOR EXAMPLE, WE
LEARNED THAT GAVIN NEWSOM WAS
SENDING HIS OWN CHILDREN TO
PRIVATE SCHOOL.
HE MADE SURE THEY COULD GET IN
PERSON CLASSROOM EDUCATION.
AND OF COURSE HE DID, THERE HIS
KIDS, HE LOVES THEM, AND HE
KNOWS WHAT WE ALL NOW KNOW, THAT
CHILDREN DON’T LEARN ANYTHING BY
REMOTE SITTING AT HOME ON THE
COMPUTER SCREEN.
IT HURTS THEM.
AT BEST IT MAKES THEM WEIRD.
THEY DON’T LEARN A THING.
AT THE SAME TIME HE WAS SENDING
HIS OWN CHILDREN TO CLASS IN A
REAL SCHOOL, THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
DISTRICTS, WHICH HE IS IN CHARGE
OF ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REMAIN CLOSED BECAUSE
HE ORDERED THEM CLOSED.
WHY DID THEY DO THAT?
THERE WAS NO SCIENCE, DIDN’T
BOTHER TO EXPLAIN IT.
SCHOOLCHILDREN DON’T FACE A
MEANINGFUL RISK FROM THIS VIRUS.
WHEN CHILDREN CONTRACT THE
VIRUS, CDC DATA SHOW THAT THEIR
SURVIVAL RATE IS OVER 99.99%.
THAT’S NOT A TV TERM.
IN THIS CASE IT’S A SCIENTIFIC
TERM.
IT LITERALLY 99.99%.
TEACHERS AND OTHER ADULTS UNDER
THE AGE OF 70 HAVE BETWEEN A
99.5 AND A 99.9% CHANCE OF
SURVIVING.
AGAIN, NOT ESTIMATES, REAL
NUMBERS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THAT’S SCIENCE, BUT NOBODY CARES
ABOUT SCIENCE ANYMORE.
A FEW HOURS AGO THE MAYOR OF
NEW YORK ANNOUNCED SHUTTING
DOMINATION’S LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
NOT BECAUSE CHILDREN ARE IN
PERIL OF SUDDENLY BECOMING ILL
IN HUGE NUMBERS, THEY ARE NOT.
HE DID THIS BECAUSE A ROLLING 70
AVERAGE OF POSITIVE CORONAVIRUS
TESTS IN NEW YORK CITY WENT OVER
3%.
NOT DEATHS, NOT HOSPITALIZATIONS
HOSPITALIZATIONS, POSITIVE
TESTS, WHICH IN THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF CASES MEAN NOTHING.
SO THAT’S INSANE, OBVIOUSLY, BUT
IT’S ACCELERATED.
WASHINGTON’S GOVERNOR JAY INSLEE
SAYS WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
CANCEL CHRISTMAS BUT WE ARE
GOING TO DO IT IN THE NAME OF
LOVE.
>> IT’S JUST TOO DANGEROUS TO
GATHER TOGETHER INDOORS WHERE
THE VIRUS CAN SPREAD SO EASILY.
SO THIS YEAR, WHEN YOU JOIN US
IN CHANGING YOUR THANKSGIVING IN
DECEMBER HOLIDAY PLANS, PLEASE
KNOW THAT YOU ARE DOING IT AS AN
ACT OF LOVE.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
AN ACT OF LOVE!
SAYS JAY INSLEE, THE POLITICIAN
LAWYER.
WHAT DO POLITICIAN LAWYERS KNOW
ABOUT LOVE?
NOT MUCH.
NORMAL PEOPLE KNOW THAT LOVE IS
IMPOSSIBLE IF YOU’RE FORCED TO
LIVE ALONE IN ISOLATION AND FEAR
FEAR.
NOW IN AN IDEAL WORLD WE WOULD
ALL BE AT THE FRENCH LAUNDRY
LAUGHING AND EATING WITH OUR
FRIENDS.
IT SOUNDS WONDERFUL.